you know I miss I miss bump the bump
those with a [ __ ] back in the day I
never understood a damn when they were
saying but I could imitate the [ __ ] out
of her I'm gonna come in if I'm
auditioning the dominant game in this
I'm on the phone I'm gonna be everybody
oh what's going on you two now we all
know in highschool hits high school is a
very weird and interesting part of your
[ __ ] life now there was one person in
high school that we all remember and you
know who that guy was that was high
school mr. cool guy
when thumb is the cool guy I missed the
cool guy mr. cool guy in high school was
the guy that thought he was too dope for
anything
what's up mr. cool guy you deal on my
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh my god is that mr. cool
are you gonna tie your shoelace tying
your shoe lace Dom I'll talk about this
too he wanted to be so [ __ ] cool
he had a go against the grain on
everything you eat breakfast [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] when I fist how you gonna say [ __ ]
breakfast dawg breakfast is the most
important meal of the [ __ ] day you
talk about [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you
oh it was so funny because when you
would walk on your high school campus
and you would see this dude he only had
a certain walk in a certain Flair about
him number one in my school this
[ __ ] always had a random gangsta
lean that [ __ ] not sure that was
accurate but it's how we all remember
this dude you know what because at the
first day of school
you already know he was the dude in the
back of the classroom with his foot up
and every time the teacher would ask him
a question he would answer some [ __ ]
stupid oh you in the back what is your
mouth [ __ ] no oh really I was in it
you don't know your name she never knows
when you do something wrong that's
usually the only thing you said she and
you know what's funny later on in life
but you find out the people that care so
much about their parents that wanted to
be cool during that moment they turned
out to be [ __ ] losers I'm not I'm not
saying that that is angel I see these
guys and it turned out to be nothing
that it makes me feel good I got a
[ __ ] you want your whole life
trying to press everybody making
everybody feel bad about themselves now
look at you huh dick all shriveled up
titties all lopsided and nobody give a
[ __ ] about god reason why I want to tell
you guys is because high school is such
a small part of your life
then during the moment that when you're
stuck in it that's all you think about
not guys
mr. high school pop with a cool guy all
he did was focus on the moment he never
thought about the future so that's what
he is stuck where he is at oh but you'll
find out later on this world that it's
never about a popularity contest it's
all about what makes you happy and
trying to find happiness and defining
who you are based on how other people
think about you is not a way to live you
are gonna be [ __ ] miserable because
trust me you know with the end of like
that guy because and my age with my
friends right now we always see that guy
still talking about high school and how
tight high school was not about how many
pitches he used to get info about how
his mom and dad are on his case because
he still said oh honey don't be a [ __ ]
[ __ ] on the phone when your mom is
yelling you at the back tell you to
clean your drawers huh [ __ ] Winkle [ __ ]
me oh oh my mom is there about the
short-end [ __ ] is about the
long game and when you win at the end oh
yes it feels so good I look to my with
you me and you seem to make a lot motion
and when I see your head of us ahead of
that the [ __ ] who texted me part of your
life and you when you want and when you
when you what I mean your mini-me